the stars were out last night for
fashions biggest night
the annual Met Gala and nearly everyone
was serving looks the gala which is an
invite-only event had an incredible
amount of queer stars and LGBTQ allies
walking the pink carpet in style the
theme of the night camp notes on fashion
so what is camp well it's nearly
impossible to pin down a single meaning
in 1964 philosopher susan sontag wrote
an essay notes on camp which listed 58
points camp isn't something ugly
exaggerated would be a great word for
camp something Laverne Cox agrees with
for me camp is about exaggeration it's
about sort of extremes I was obsessed
with Susan Sontag essay actually in
college and so for me it was just it
felt perfect for me to be here with my
love of camp and all that it represents
now it's very important to note the camp
originated within the black brown and
queer communities which makes it an
important mechanism for those of us
within the LGBTQ community especially
because the queer community has no doubt
perfected camp and continue to bring
camp to the mainstream Lina weights used
her mikela fashion to remind people that
black drag queens invented camp and get
this the suit actually had the lyrics to
Diana Ross's I'm coming out and Gloria
Gaynor's I Will Survive about it to me
when I heard a camp
you got appearances burnin thought a
Lily ninja about a RuPaul and I'm like
all these amazing black human beings you
know really kind of dentist just a that
we call camp Lady Gaga is also someone
who has embraced camp since the
beginning of her career and as co-chair
of last night's Met Gala Gaga once again
proved she is the queen of any event
revealing for yes four different looks
in 15 minutes
incredible now some of you are probably
saying why does this matter it's just a
bunch of rich people in clothes well it
matters because black and LGBTQ history
matters and representation matters our
LGBTQ community shut down that pink
carpet last night and it serves as a
reminder of the power of fashion oh and
I got to mention some of these other
looks of the night because they are
fantastic
Ezra Miller Janelle Monae Billy Porter
well the kids call it extra for many
many years it's been used as a
pejorative and I think when you have
something like this you know it brings
the respect back to something that is
high high arts high crafts you know I've
built a career on playing campy
characters you know I have a career I
have this life Cara Delevingne
Kacey Musgraves what did you think of
last night's Met Gala theme who do you
think had the best look of the night
what would you have worn to the Met Gala
let me know in the comments below and
don't forget to subscribe to ET Canada's
YouTube page
[Music]